uh-huh okay great
word on the street is conservatism is
the new punk rock just ask Alex Jones's
British sidekick leftist the desperately
clinging to this idea that they have the
monopoly on cool conservatism is the new
punk rock and while the old punk rock
was a subculture of anti-establishment
teenagers screaming into a microphone
about being a misunderstood and
underrepresented the new punk rock is
just as cool and just as
anti-establishment and even the
lamestream media agrees of course
technically the right controls like the
whole establishment but whatever
conservatives are underrepresented
hardcore punk and we have a badass
message for the lives conservatism is
the new punk rock hell yeah I'm excited
to prove how punk rock me and my friends
are that's why I came to the hip new
youth movement CPAC which is being held
at today's version of the CBGB's the
Gaylord National Resort and Convention
Center
it's a mosh pit of Magha hats plastic
lanyards and golf putters nothing here
is mainstream it's not even safe
conservatism is a new punk rock because
it involves rebelling against the
establishment and going our own way it's
all about going against the
establishment it's time it's rebellion
its rebranding being a Republican is a
punk rock type finger it's rebellious
just got out of it it's like there's so
many already just jump around and stuff
in some gags yeah jumping around and
going wild just like conservatives and
everyone has crystal clear reasons why
conservatism
is a punk rock because I think so I
guess I asked how a good analogy okay so
it took a second to think about
specifics but really the new
conservative movement is totally plumb
how was trauma pumped how was he
alright so he gets out of office and he
says I want tax reform at home one thing
that's Punk is cutting taxes what's
another I would personally say
immigration so deporting people is Punk
let me rephrase that legal merit-based
migration is possible moving the US
Embassy in Israel from Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem that's number three pawn punk
punk number Punk's here totally fun part
these new park ideas in no way remind me
of the past forty years of traditional
Republican doctrine just wrapped up in a
new slogan meant to attract younger
voters conservatives are definitely
pumped you're not punks you've co-opted
the language from punk rock but it
doesn't make it pop this is Damian
Abraham of the seminal punk band
up
supposedly an expert on punk rock and
just because he's in one of the biggest
independent punk bands spent 15 years
touring and also bleeding on his fans he
thinks he knows more than me
Tim Tim balls punk music is all about
being anti-authority and like there's
nothing more anti-authority than
becoming president but then you're the
authority punk isn't just this anarchy
symbol it's about looking at things
around you and kind of seeing through
the BS you know I've been listening to a
lot of my favorite commentators on
YouTube they are saying that like our
movement is punk
can you name like a single pump in oh oh
I hate punk music I just want to say
controversial stuff that gets me
attention because that's Punk Damian
thinks that if I'm going to call myself
punk I need to learn the basics of punk
but little does he know that the little
or that I know allows me to pretend that
I have a full understanding of a thing
that he thinks I know little about punk
has always been a fairly inclusive place
the class you have songs they're talking
about anti racism they're talking about
anti-fascism you have bands like the Bad
Brains
a group of black kids in DC right girl
women that felt underrepresented or not
represented at all Michael of different
sexualities trans people bands in
California like Black Flag you have Dead
Kennedys Dead Kennedys now that's a band
I think I can get behind
Wow Damien sure has a lot to teach but I
zone out when I start hearing things I
don't want to hear it seems like you're
getting really hung up on the music
aspect of the punk thing you need to
understand that conservatives are punks
without the music then what would make
them Punk so what you're saying is we
need some of our own music to really
unite the message that we are putting
out there what like with you singing in
a punk band Damien it just made
a really good point
[Applause]
[Music]
a couple businesses this sucks this is
like a more corporate shittier warped or
what's worked or Donald Regan and Jesus
Christ cooperation the very night